poor me it's something we tell ourselves
a lot as entrepreneurs and it causes a
cycle of depression that we don't know
how to get out of if you're thinking
poor me right now with your business
this can be a hard for you to build
something successful and it's okay to
get down it's going to happen you know
riding a running the business like
riding a roller coaster but you can't
stay down for too long I know it's hard
with my first business I was making
three hundred dollars a month and it
wasn't enough to survive and and I was
at poor me almost every day at different
points and it built up and up and up and
and and made it really hard to continue
and even if I had a great day one day
you know we've got some sales we brought
somebody new onto the team whatever it
was some great news from the next day
was still hard getting up out of bed and
going to work and if you stay there for
too long it's going to be hard to get
out of it so the question that came in
from from one of my youtube viewers
Linna we're didn't say how do you get
out of poor me depression I guess I just
need to to think that no one else will
do it if it's not me it's a dog-eat-dog
world I got to start biting back Selena
here's what helped me and here's what
hopefully can help you what changed with
me what changed to help me break out on
my poor me method was was one really
make sure that your business is around
something that you are intensely
passionate about when I change my focus
and I started talking about
entrepreneurs and helping entrepreneurs
and I knew that that meant something to
me you know for you may not mean
anything and that's cool but it's my
personal belief and passion that may be
more excited that made me want to get
out of bed number two was I started
looking at the impact that I was having
so for example I might go on and do a
presentation to help entrepreneurs
deliver a speech
and I feel great you know that whole
night I feel wow I really helped all
these people I feel really great on top
of the world and then I wake up the next
day and it's like I'm starting over from
scratch so to keep the momentum going in
between I saved some of the comments
that people wrote some of my favorite
comments and people are written down on
the feedback sheet and I read them in
the morning and that made me feel better
it made me break out of my funk it made
me want to go and do something again to
feel that hi to help more people and the
third thing I did was I created a
mastermind group and this is a group of
entrepreneurs we meet once a month and
we connect by phone once a week and it's
just another group of entrepreneurs to
share ideas with to let to let loose the
thoughts that I'm facing and it's just
great to be around other business owners
I find a lot of a lot of entrepreneurs
most of the time we don't have friends
and family who are business owners so
people will listen to us but they don't
really know what to say to help us so
it's great but it doesn't solve the
problem and then when we are meeting
people it's usually always all the great
stuff right if you go to a networking
event it's always I just landed this big
sale or reliant working on this huge new
deal or brought on new team members
whatever it is you're always talking
about the great stuff but who you tell
the crap to who do you tell the you know
I hate my business right now what do I
do who do you tell that to so I having a
group of entrepreneurs you can meet was
once a month some of us call it
entrepreneur's anonymous it helps it
helps you keep you motivated so try to
find a group or start your own it can
help you get out your your your funk
your comment about it being a
dog-eat-dog world and you gotta fight
back I totally disagree with I don't
think it's a dog-eat-dog world you think
that way you're fighting against the
world all the time I'd rather work with
it I love helping my customers I love
helping entrepreneurs and I found the
way to do that follow my passion and be
successful make money at the same time
and that's where I want you to get
because if you wake up with a negative
attitude you're never going to have
success if you're forcing yourself to go
and do something you're not going to
have success it's got to come from here
it's got to be something that you love
it's gotta be from a place of passion a
place if I want to change the world I
want to have a real impact that's where
you start having success and I know it's
hard I know it's hard when people tell
you you're never going to make it when
people say eighty percent of new
businesses fail when people say that's a
stupid idea when you don't have a
support network around you it's it's
hard it's tough and the only thing that
keeps you going is the belief that what
you're doing is right that you're on the
right path that you're here to make a
mark that you're helping people that's
what always kept me going was the
helping people part I wasn't money it
wasn't anything else it was I know that
today I can get up and go help somebody
and have a real lasting meaningful
impact on their life that gets me
excited that guess that makes me want to
do more so hopefully you can find that
within yourself again look at you know
what your passion is try to follow that
look at the impact you've already had
with your customers and let that feed
your momentum and three look at other
entrepreneurs you can connect with on a
formal basis like a mastermind group or
even just grabbing coffee once a month
to talk about what's going on in your
company's it'll help pull you up but
help get you out of your funk I help you
start building a company that you can be
proud of and look back 10 years and say
I built that belief
those are you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes you want to do more for
you and please leave a comment below if
you like the video just say that you
like the video below the comments I love
seeing those come in they really make my
morning every day and if you have a
question leave it below i'll make a
video response just like this thank you
so much i'll see you soon